hello my name is Professor James
fountain and I part of the global agenda
council on the future of government our
Council has been meeting right now for
four years we've been working on issues
of how many governments work better how
to improve them and also the issue of
social media and governance so in terms
of governments working better we have an
acronym we've been developing holdfast
government and mana that we being
flattered governments more agile
governments streamlines governments and
tech enables technology-enabled
governments in the area of social media
we've been examining how civil society
members are using social media in order
to participate in their political
systems and their society societal
systems and we've been looking at how
government officials elected and
appointed and civil servants are using
social media to better communicate a
challenge as the opportunities and the
issues of common man's